what is the worst thing about my country
the worst thing about Mike Huckabee is
that he's turned in to Sarah Palin if
you listen to mike huckabee speech the
great stuff that he communicates about
is himself is his travails with the
mainstream media mm-hmm his wealth all
must hear about that that email list
he's got that who cares yeah the biggest
problem Mike Huckabee has now is that
he's talking about himself and he's
become a TV star he is not he's kind of
lost touch I think with his roots as an
Arkansas governor and he still kind of
sometimes you can you know again talks
wonderfully and he communicates
wonderfully you can hear him voc back to
it but he's lost touch yeah Mike
Huckabee has lost touch with in talks
about himself too much so whatever
that's that that's a really unattractive
thing for for a candidate like Huckabee
who has such such gifts yeah and a good
record too so they have a guy who had a
TV show for the last four years is
talking too much about himself I find
that hard to believe people on TV do not
like to of course we really know I yeah
but it doesn't it is a it's a corrosive
effective of him being on television I
think in frankly money how much do you
think the social stuff hurts him because
it's very easy for us here in LA or in
New York whatever to say all right the
gay marriage stuff like you're obviously
on the wrong side of history and
whatever now I wouldn't have voted for
him either way to be honest but do you
think just to get through the Republican
primary he's still doing the right I
mean he believes it that's the one thing
that you'll say about Mike Mike Huckabee
believes that gay marriage is a sin
against God doesn't matter what Supreme
Court says yeah so he's not gonna change
that position yeah maybe know we have a
separation between churches iiieee I
think he understood you get the
understand Constitution says but for him
you know God exist prior to the
Constitution he was a pastor remember he
was that's you know you and I might not
you know subscribe to that view but the
key to understanding Huckabee is to kind
of put yourself in the shoes and that's
what he believes so yeah I don't think
the general election is going to be
fought over those issues and I don't
think Huckabee's going to be there for
the general election and I don't think
is gonna hurt a Republican primary
either I mean initially the
he just Republican voters even public
and voters who don't like the
evangelical wing of their party you know
they'll support someone who they think
can win I don't know if Republicans
think he could win because again he's
not talking to them about things that
that they want to hear about he's
talking about himself yeah which is not
fascinating after after ten times yeah
well he had a show it's called Huckabee
but no matter thank you think about that
anyway what do you think about Mike
Huckabee let us know in the comments
right now